[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
major announcement
everyone pay attention turn the volume
up
hot off the presses
Donald Trump is a [ __ ] pathetic loser
major announcement Donald Trump
is a pathetic [ __ ] loser holy [ __ ]
I really had no clue what we were gonna
talk about today I was going to talk
about John Boehner uh how much he loved
Nancy Pelosi
and
the gifts just keep on grifting holy
actual [ __ ] if you have not
been on Twitter this morning or anywhere
else on the internet for that matter
Donald Trump's major announcement
yesterday we played the video
the the the the the trailer or the
teaser the the sizzle reel that he had
yesterday about how
America needs a [ __ ] superhero
which in and of itself
like the [ __ ] teaser video yesterday
in and of itself
[Music]
oh you cannot make this [ __ ] up you just
can't listen
former President George
W bush paints okay
he's a painter now you know it may be
good painting it may not it depends on
your opinion right
Bill Clinton the former President Bill
Clinton has the Clinton Foundation
okay
um huge charity gave money all around
the world
Jimmy Carter is still alive Jimmy Carter
former president
has Habitat for Humanity
build houses for people who cannot
afford them
and he literally builds them with his
own bare hands I'm not [ __ ] you
still in his 90s dude still goes out
and builds these houses with his own
[ __ ] bare hands
Barack Obama
has a foundation but also Barack Obama
is producing many award-winning
documentaries
some of the most highly produced films
that we've seen
for documentaries
in the last few years
so what former presidents are doing
okay
the Cheeto dust cue in honor
thank you
I can't even I it's hard to even [ __ ]
put it in perspective here
this [ __ ]
is selling digital
trading cards okay
for 99 bucks a piece
and let me tell you if the images that
they're showing on Twitter right now of
these trading cards these superhero
trading cards
of this [ __ ] idiot if those are real
literally they took the [ __ ] lowest
bid on Fiverr for those pieces of
garbage
holy [ __ ] literally the right wing
yesterday was like oh my God he's
got he's Carrie Lake who's going to be
the vice president
what's the announcement gonna be
dudes grifting
his supporters is the major announcement
a total [ __ ] full-on laughable
pathetic grift
he is not a billionaire folks he is not
rich folks he's broke as a [ __ ] joke
and he's cornered and trapped
this is not this is not a sign and
really honestly
um I think I think I'm gonna make a joke
out of it
in in the literal sense that I'm gonna
make my own trading cards
maybe we'll give them away maybe we'll
sell them for 99 cents a piece I don't
know what a [ __ ] joke this guy is
and maybe I'll just go to Fiverr and
find the cheapest [ __ ]
bid that you can get to make a digital
trading card not you know they're
calling them nfts but that's not what
he's going we got the announcement got
the images we got the video of him
saying what the announcement is
I just I can't even believe
that these [ __ ] boneheads
are still sending him [ __ ] money
and of all things for a digital trading
card
which anyone is going to be out and if
you know anything about nfts right
you know anything or been reading any
kind of news on it we've we actually had
Anthony scaramucci on back in March I
think it was March and he was talking
about crypto and nft
trying to explain it trying to convince
Gabe Sanchez that nft was a good deal or
some [ __ ] which oh I I highly disagreed
with Anthony scaramucci at the time on
that I still do probably I don't know if
Anthony still loves uh nfts maybe I
should call him and bring him on again
and see what he thinks about these Trump
trading cards what a [ __ ] pathetic
joke
anyone is going to be able to just grab
these images he is selling these not 99
for the whole collection folks literally
he is selling them 99 a piece and and if
again if these images of what these
trading cards actually are and I'm gonna
show them to you or you know we're going
to look at them here
at the Tony Michaels podcast of course
we are we're going to mock the ever
loving [ __ ]
out of these stupid bastards
you thought an eight dollar blue check
on Twitter
you were gonna be able to point and
laugh at someone
if anyone has or bought
these Trump trading cards holy actual
[ __ ]
it it will be the most mockable
situation
and the right-wing media is going to go
crazy over this
you watch you watch and they're probably
already saying right now this is the
greatest thing ever it's the greatest
thing that a former president has ever
done ever because America does really
need a superhero I'm telling you Jan
they need a superhero right now
and it is it is amazing that President
Donald Trump has delivered us the
ability to see him as our superhero I'm
literally that's the [ __ ] they're gonna
be saying
oan Newsmax Fox News watch you [ __ ]
watch I'm gonna play the clip tomorrow
we'll have the clips tomorrow of them
saying some stupid ass [ __ ] about these
[ __ ] digital trading cards that is
only a grift it's just a grift it's
nothing else that's all it is he's
[ __ ] broke he ain't got no money he's
running out of it he's running out of
time out of money out of Freedom he's
[ __ ] and this is a sign of that
desperation can you even [ __ ] imagine
the meeting
think about this they're sitting around
a [ __ ] table
with the former supposedly the former
president of the United States
he's running to be the president again
and they're they're great idea
they're great idea
is to get half-assed [ __ ] digital
artwork make him into a quote superhero
and sell them for 99 bucks a piece does
that sound like someone who's got his
[ __ ] together
this is worse than commemorative coins
okay
way worse way worse than the trump card
way worse than the Trump Flags in the
Maga hats
this is well beyond that this is so
[ __ ] mockable
and everyone should mock this
every single [ __ ] day and never
let up
and what we have to do is tie this
narrative to the Republican Party he's
their [ __ ] leader
he's the presumptive nominee of their
party
for president of the United States
for a third loss in the popular vote
that's the this and this is why
this is why
because he's a pathetic [ __ ] joke a
pathetic [ __ ] loser holy
[ __ ]
uh I I don't know that it could get much
easier folks some people are like Tony
you can't you can't want Trump to be
their nominee that's dangerous really
is it
after this morning after this joke
it's a he's a threat to what
to the nft market everything Trump
touches turns to liquid [ __ ] so I
wouldn't be surprised if the entire nft
Market bottoms today
[ __ ] them they own it he's theirs
but you have to make him theirs and I'm
telling you it's going to be easy oh
it's going to be so [ __ ] easy
I don't I I haven't looked at the Nick
Adams you know you know Nick Adams is
this guy I it it's almost like
now that I'm thinking about it this was
Nick Adams idea
that's how [ __ ] dumb that guy is he's
the alpha male on Twitter the
self-proclaimed alpha male who tweets
out that alpha males don't have to don't
have to self-proclaim themselves alpha
male while he's self-broke it's [ __ ]
dumb
he's such a dumb [ __ ] I would not be
surprised now that I'm thinking about it
if this was Nick Adams idea
I mean think about it
I bet Gabe Sanchez will agree with me
when he comes on today
this is a hundred percent the doing of
Nick Adams
I'm probably the first one to say that
[ __ ] I should tweet it really to give
proof of course here's proof on video
now my [ __ ] God I cannot believe
I I was here's what I was going to talk
about
I was going to talk about Nancy Pelosi
um being uh remembered by John Boehner
with just [ __ ] waterfalls of Tears Of
course John Boehner He he'll cry if the
wind blows you know
so it's not surprising he gets all
choked up
when he goes to and give remembrance
to the first female speaker at one point
was his nemesis
but it was heartfelt
now Boehner is uh you know he's a human
being he has some Humanity left in him
so he was able to muster up some good
words to say
about the most effective speaker of the
house that we've seen in modern times
that's what I was going to talk about
and here we are because you can't not
mock them okay and I was gonna mock John
Boehner right this morning this this was
gonna be the stick I was gonna mock him
for crying and this the guy and then
they moved on they got Paul Ryan he
didn't want to be speaker because Kevin
McCarthy failed we were going to get
into the talk about Kevin McCarthy not
getting 218 he's probably at 214 215
maybe this morning he's at 213 who knows
to get votes for speaker
that's what I was going to talk about
that's how I was gonna do my mockery you
know mock them that's the whole point of
this show
we have to continue to mock them we have
to continue the narrative we got to keep
messaging to beat these [ __ ]
nincompoop Nazis and boy this morning
did they prove that they're [ __ ]
nincompoops
with this [ __ ] digital Trading Card
[ __ ] it it gets it just gets better and
better and better yesterday the the
[ __ ] teaser trailer and this morning
puts out a video he has a tweet with the
art excuse me a a a truth over on fraud
social he posts an image of him in the
superhero suit with like a it's got like
a wrestling belt
like a like a like a professional
wrestling belt folks what do I say every
[ __ ] week I say it we are at the
intersection of WrestleMania in real
life and this [ __ ] puts it right
out on his [ __ ] truth account
an image here I'll [ __ ] pull it up
I'll show you yeah that's the that's the
trailer here it is
of course it looks like a a q Anon thing
doubt me there it is see it's a [ __ ]
it's a world champion wrestling bill
that says Trump champion
we I I've been saying this for [ __ ]
years we are at the intersection of
WrestleMania and real life and here it
is
more proof that I'm correct
it never fails
it never fails it's so easy to see what
these [ __ ] chuckleheads are gonna do
it's not complicated and then the
[ __ ] oh my God the the artwork is
ridiculous this is horrible Photoshop by
the way
and the
[ __ ] oh
you know you know that this [ __ ]
that this [ __ ] when he when he
looks in the mirror this is what the
[ __ ] he sees can you imagine
can you imagine how much money they
gotta go through with mirrors because
they gotta find the right [ __ ] mirror
and he's getting and they probably put
an x on the ground for him to stand at a
certain distance to make sure it's
optimal
viewing in that mirror for him to
[ __ ] imagine himself like this in the
mirror
you know what he really looks like I
mean I could bring him a picture but
he's a fat [ __ ] slob that's not even
close
to Donald Trump and again this look it's
a wrestling ring even
I mean I hate to say that I'm I'm
[ __ ] correct all the time but how
[ __ ] perfect is that
WrestleMania in real life we are at the
intersection of it it's a q Anon World
we're just living in it folks holy [ __ ]
oh my God I can't even it's it's it's
astounding to me and of course we're
gonna go through this today but we do we
do have some news there is some real
news
uh other than this major announcement
there is some real news it looks like
the uh DC Bar Association uh has
concluded that Rudy Giuliani has
committed at least one violation of
attorney rules in his legal efforts to
overturn the 2020 election
um which means that it's probably likely
that he is going to have some some sort
of suspension at the very least of his
law license uh and and and we'll see
about the Jack Smith and the grand jury
what the hell is going to happen there
and so there's that news let's see what
else is in the news I got totally
sidetracked and distracted and by this
major announcement of course it's it's
all trending yeah Trump trading cards is
training Jesus Christ
you just can't make this [ __ ] up
again I was going to talk about the John
Boehner thing
and of course John Boehner came to
remember Nancy Pelosi as the Speaker of
the House you know that
John Boehner was the speaker of the
house when Nancy Pelosi was the minority
leader
yeah they they were nemesis
as it were in the House of
Representatives and he had great words
to say about Nancy Pelosi
and again I'm not always in agreeance
with Nancy or a fan but I'll tell you
what she was the Trump Kryptonite right
absolutely Trump Kryptonite he couldn't
handle it she was one of the most
effective speakers that in modern times
I mean look look at the speakers that we
had
John Boehner [ __ ] worthless
he he might as well needed a mop to mop
up his tears half the time and Brandy to
wash down his feelings
and then you had Paul Ryan who did not
want to be speaker that's really the
story here of Kevin McCarthy now I don't
know if you remember this John Boehner
was going to retire right Kevin McCarthy
second in line he was going to become
the speaker he goes on Fox News and he
opens his big [ __ ] mouth about the
Benghazi hearing and Hillary Clinton
she's running for president he's like
well
you know the reason why we have the
Benghazi special committee is so that we
could politically damage Hillary Clinton
and it worked and everyone's like hey
[ __ ] idiot that
that is not the public reason why we had
the committee the Benghazi committee
shut the [ __ ] up and he obviously was
too incompetent to be speakers still is
but it forced Paul Ryan to be speaker he
did not want to be you remember he's
like running away from the media they're
like are you gonna be a speaker he's
like hell to the no and then a couple
days later he's like yes I'll I'll be
speaker no one else wants to be no one
no one
wanted to be Speaker of the House think
about that for a second
think about all these Republican [ __ ]
politicians right think about it
and this is before Trump won
because you know when when when Trump
won the Electoral College
he didn't win the popular vote
he would never win the popular vote
never
this [ __ ] country hates that [ __ ]
idiot
we [ __ ] hate him
but Paul Ryan was the speaker
When Donald Trump became the president
of the United States and they couldn't
get [ __ ] done the only thing they were
capable of doing is making sure that
rich people received a permanent [ __ ]
tax cut
and [ __ ] the rest of us that's all they
did what else did they do tell me give
me an example I mean they tried to
[ __ ] take away everyone's right to
Health Care they tried to do that they
failed John McCain made sure of it
but no one in the Republican Party
wanted to be the speaker of the house
nobody
there wasn't one [ __ ] even the
guy who became speaker Paul Ryan didn't
want the job
and the reason why is because at the
Wrestlemania real life thing they do not
know how to govern
they don't know
and really it's it's difficult to govern
it's difficult to set policy it's
difficult to be a serious policy maker
that's really [ __ ] hard [ __ ]
I mean it's difficult stuff it's not
easy [ __ ] you got to be a smart
[ __ ] you got to be on top of it
and you gotta have an impeccable staff
to manage to be a policy maker
even your representative even your
Congress person can't go alone to
Washington and be a great policy maker
and a great lawmaker
it takes an entire staff to do that kind
of [ __ ]
and not no [ __ ] loser dumb [ __ ] like
these trumped up moglodytes
that a lot of these Republicans have on
their staff imagine having to be the
leader of all that
and managing the floor of the house what
comes to the floor
trying to not only manage the politics
of it all
but also for the American people because
you got a job to do
and these people don't want to [ __ ]
work
have you ever have you ever looked at
Jim Jordan thought oh that guy's working
hard
yeah he's working hard to get on Fox
news that [ __ ] dirtbag
so Kevin McCarthy couldn't be speaker
because he was
absolutely incompetent
so Paul Ryan was forced to be the
Speaker of the House
and as soon as the Democrats went back
to House Majority Nancy Pelosi becomes
the speaker again
without fail she steps right into the
leadership role she isn't like whoa
uh-uh no [ __ ] way that's hard work I
ain't want nothing to do with it no she
[ __ ] stepped up not only did you step
up she was [ __ ] effective
foreign
that's why history will say in this time
in this history
that we're living in this weird [ __ ]
timeline
that she was the most effective house
speaker that we have had because if
Kevin McCarthy does manage to [ __ ]
eke out 218 here if he [ __ ] manages
it which he it doesn't seem like he's
going to really honestly I don't know
how the [ __ ] he's gonna do this there
ain't going to be a demograph vote for
that [ __ ]
and he keeps it looks like he's going
from like 213 to 16 back down to 214.
he can't manage to hold his caucus
together what do you think being speaker
is you have to hold your caucus together
you have to hold the [ __ ] floor you
have to hold the votes and he can't
manage to get 218. that's why you need
218 to be speaker
because it's part of the job
oh [ __ ] these people are stupid bastards
you [ __ ] right-wing Republican
America First Nazis are a bunch of
stupid bastards
and when you elect these dumb
[ __ ] to be your representatives
you even prove how [ __ ] much Dumber
you are
like Marjorie Taylor green and Lauren
bober what a stupid [ __ ] idea that
[ __ ] is
as if they have any kind of serious
policy notion in their entire [ __ ]
offices all their offices all their
staff themselves
and anyone around them and think tanks
trying to send them bills lobbyists
they're just [ __ ] dumb
and Kevin McCarthy you think this is
gonna fix no listen we are probably
gonna get a vote sometime today more
likely tomorrow of a continuing
resolution what a CR is is it basically
gives the federal government the ability
to keep paying their bills
right that Congress has already [ __ ]
all it's the it's the debt ceiling
basically it we're just trying to
prevent a shutdown they're gonna kick
that can in the next week because they
want to work a deal to wear it they can
Kick the Can again until September
but the reason why the Congress has to
keep kicking the can is it because of
Democrats
it's because Republicans are [ __ ]
worthless
they're [ __ ] worthless
they can't work themselves out of a wet
paper sack let alone come up with a
[ __ ] budget that can be compromised
that's good for their [ __ ]
constituency no they don't give a [ __ ]
they want to get highlights for [ __ ]
Fox News they want to go yell and scream
about high gas prices that are coming
down they want to [ __ ] talk about
inflation which is receding
yesterday the fed the FED is going to
raise the interest rate by half a point
Which is less than what they what they
projected because inflation is is
dissipating of course it is
we said this would happen they kept the
administration kept saying hey we know
it's not happening as fast as we want it
but because of the cause and effect of
inflation it will recede
and it is
Democrats are effective folks
they're effective
and the only reason why is because we as
[ __ ] pro-democracy Coalition vote in
serious people most of the time
and what I mean by that is someone who
is [ __ ] serious about making policy
and half the time that's our problem
with our narrative and messaging is
we're so focused on line items and bills
that we're not paying attention
to the brainless that are going to go
vote for these morons because they're
making [ __ ] digital trading cards
that make them look like [ __ ]
superheroes [ __ ] pathetic jokes
and yes we need our own circus we need
our own circus
we can still elect serious people to be
making policy
that's what primaries are for folks
Democratic primaries are to make sure
that we have serious people Republican
primaries or make sure they have Nazis
in their in their [ __ ] elections
ours are a little different we believe
in democracy so we use it to advance
democracy they want to use democracy to
kill democracy that's why they they want
to vote in a bunch of [ __ ] Nazis
but we can still vote in serious people
and have the clown show that's me I'm
the [ __ ] circus
I wish I wish the the Democratic
apparatus would realize that
I'm the [ __ ] on the rodeo clown I'm
the one that's supposed to distract you
and show you what the [ __ ] going on
entertain you make you pay attention
we need to have our own style cpacks
I'm telling you
even if we just pretend to be a cult
and you come here every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central I'm so glad to have you here
today what a day to be alive today and
it's going to be a great show I'm
telling you great show Gabe Sanchez is
going to join us here in just a little
bit for the shitless Roundup and then Dr
Rachel bidikoffer
I was gonna ask her yesterday I I was
trying to get her on the show she's
coming on today uh at the top of the
second hour uh and I was I was gonna
have doc
um break down how we draw wedges between
DeSantis and Trump
but you know what that's today I think
I'm gonna just let her give you a master
class on how to mock these [ __ ]
and there's no better example than this
morning
with this major announcement that Trump
made oh my God it's going over like a
wet fart in a white thong everyone stick
around
me back with a [ __ ] list Roundup right
after this
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another
momentum we're
[Music]
to the Tony Michaels podcast
every single one of gate changes
parodies and satire
to get better and better every move
these morons make it
[Music]
I can't remember when he made this Trump
fun one but God damn that was it had to
have been and had to have been in 2020 I
believe I believe it's when he's first
started joining the show as executive
producer I know when he gets on here I'm
gonna ask him about this
that Trump fund one
because that's what this [ __ ] is this
this [ __ ] nft digital trump card
whatever the [ __ ] this thing is holy
[ __ ]
it's it's so stupid
how
how did we get here
right like you ever stop and think about
like how in the [ __ ] did we get
ourselves as a country
in a situation where this [ __ ] dumb
[ __ ]
could ever have a chance
of actually having any kind of
political
movement
and it's not it's not only just the end
supporters it's a [ __ ] cult man holy
can you imagine
think about this for a second there are
[ __ ] out there right now as I'm
talking as you're listening to me that
are gobbling up and giving him hundreds
of dollars probably thousands of dollars
so they can get an email with these
[ __ ] shitty images
of his head half-assed photoshopped
onto onto [ __ ] bodies that don't even
aren't even close to what his what his
[ __ ] torso
and he looks like not even [ __ ] close
think about that they literally I mean
right now as we speak they're typing in
their [ __ ] credit card numbers
probably transferring uh Equity from
their mortgages
it's a [ __ ] sickness I mean yeah we
want to laugh at the [ __ ] cards and
how bad they are and how stupid the
[ __ ] announcement and how stupid the
major announcement is and what a [ __ ]
pathetic loser he is
but these people are [ __ ] gonna do it
they're gonna get they're gonna give him
their [ __ ] money for this [ __ ]
and again I I
I'm saying I I would not be surprised
that this is all Nick Adams idea this is
his if this is his doing this really
seems right up that alley
doesn't it
when you see the images it's definitely
why I showed you the one
of him with the uh the [ __ ] the
wrestling belt
I mean look at that one here and let me
show you this one yeah there it is
the one with the wrestling belt right
here
I mean even I mean the face looked like
Trump but it's that this is a horrible
Photoshop because even the the [ __ ]
head-to-body ratio is all off
it's horrible
horrible his hands are not even close to
that big he definitely does not look
like that at all
I mean he's a he's a fat [ __ ] slob
you ever see him with this [ __ ] his
grandpa britches on when he's walking
around Mar-A-Lago he's got his [ __ ]
belt pulled up to his tits
he's got stains all over his goddamn uh
former president white polos
he's got that stupid oversized Maga hat
on
to keep his hair from blowing off
he's got [ __ ] stains in his undies I'm
sure ours depends
and this is the image
that they're going to pay 99 bucks for
it folks these [ __ ] are gonna
pay 99
to have a copy a digital copy of what I
got on the screen when you just go rob
it you need to screenshot that [ __ ]
everyone knows what the screen chat is
right
don't these [ __ ] know how to
screenshot
surely they do right
I mean that's that's really the knock on
nfts and when we had Anthony
scaramuccion in March
that was Gabe Sanchez's argument like
yeah I mean right so you have a you know
it's a certification and you know
there's there's the office
authentication that's embedded into the
image and [ __ ] but who gives a [ __ ]
who cares
[ __ ] gets robbed all the time we've made
a lot of images here and a lot of images
get robbed a lot of people get upset
when when there's a meme that is going
around and there's no nobody's handle or
anything on it
and you you grab it
from from I don't know inside of a
thread and you go post it somewhere like
where's the credit I'm like credit for
what I robbed it from a person who
robbed it from this person who robbed it
from this person
it's a screenshot [ __ ] what do
you want from me
I mean I'm not opposed to giving people
credit when they put their [ __ ]
handle on the art Gabe Sanchez you know
he puts his handle on the art I mean
unless it's a fake Trump statement
and he's trying to trick uh Santa Abram
Abramson
which he gets really upset about fake
images
but but again this is just all this is
it's just a [ __ ] digital image
and really you could probably
an actual graphic artist could take a
screenshot of this [ __ ] thing
and actually do a better job and pasting
his head with Photoshop
onto this onto this [ __ ] ridiculous
looking body
and again I I want to point out
that I'm correct yeah I want to point
out that I'm correct that I'm right I've
been right and will continue to be
correct
that we are at the intersection of
WrestleMania in real life literally this
[ __ ] puts out an image on his
truth social his fraud Social account
where he's in a wrestling ring
with a wrestling belt on
and it's wrestling because there's no
[ __ ] boxing gloves he ain't got
boxing gloves
it's a wrestling ring
and it says Trump if you look close it
says Trump champion on the Belt
what a [ __ ] pathetic loser what a
joke
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me
and it only proves that I'm correct that
yes we are at the intersection of
WrestleMania in real life this is
this is dumb stuff okay here's what
we're gonna do Gabe same Chance is going
to join us here in just a minute so but
what we're going to do is we're going to
go through the [ __ ] list Roundup as he
joins us uh we're gonna go watch these
videos yesterday's video today's video
I'm gonna show you these images of
apparently what is actually being
purchased for 99
a piece
on this [ __ ] website
that he's set up for these [ __ ] nfts
so let's round up the Tweety tweets and
trendy Trends start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
part of the show where we round up all
the Tweety tweets and trendy Trends to
show you what's going on in the world
how to mock them what the narrative is
the messaging you know all that kind of
good stuff I was going to talk about and
we're going to play the uh the video of
John Boehner absolutely bawling uh when
he's talking about Nancy Pelosi because
he loves Nancy oh man
he loves her he loves her so much
I worked in a bar my dad's bar and I
love the explosion it's it's it's it's
heart touching it's heartfelt it'll warm
me up on the inside
but we're also going to go through this
[ __ ] major announcement [ __ ]
yes that's what we're gonna do today so
if you don't like it leave but if you
want to stay and make fun of these
[ __ ] and learn how to mock them
stay here because at the top of the hour
here in just a little bit uh Rachel
bittickoffer is going to be joining us
that's right
Rachel bittickoffer Dr Rachel bidicoff
for the political strategist and I'm
going to make sure that I ask her
exactly how you the audience should be
mocking the Republicans and for this
major announcement [ __ ] but one thing I
want to go to First here
um on rounding up between tweets and
training Trends here is Kyle Chaney I
told you earlier in the first half hour
there that uh Rudy Giuliani is in big
trouble uh he says happening now this
was this was this morning it's a couple
hours ago Happening Now disciplinary
Committee of the D.C Bar Association has
concluded the Rudy Giuliani committed at
least one violation of attorney rules in
his legal efforts to overturn the 2020
election
it is a primarily finding preliminary
finding excuse me uh but could uh
procedure what's to come so in other
words
and it's only going to get worse for uh
Rudy colludi Grandpa farty mccharty
and Rudy Giuliani there's another video
while we're waiting for Gabe Sanchez
because I definitely do not want to go
anywhere um Beyond because I want to ask
Gabe about this he's a graphic artist
you know he's the professional here at
the Tony Michaels podcast when it comes
to design and graphic arts I definitely
want to make sure
we get his professional expert opinion
his analysis
it were of these images that we're going
to show but there was a video yesterday
um um oh let's see his name is Glenn
grothman he's a republican from
Wisconsin
um and and you know President Joe Biden
just signed the equality of Marriage Act
which codifies uh the lgbtq community to
to get married to the same sex it
codifies interracial marriage
which is crazy that we're already at
2022 and
that is not something that's catified
and Republicans want to turn that he
just in a racial marriage back
but this is where we're at and the
reason why is because of this this Glenn
grothman and when talking about violence
this hearing was about violence against
the lgbtq community
against our [ __ ] brothers and sisters
our countrymen
violence against him because of who they
are you remember what happened in Club Q
in Colorado
a [ __ ] Maga psychopath
with a weapon of War goes into
um a a an establishment where the lgbtq
community felt safe
and murdered five of them injuring more
it's just lucky there were actual Heroes
Trump actual Heroes there to save more
lives
but um Glenn grotman here this [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
he decides to conflate of course he does
violence
against white people that's what he's
saying here that's what the [ __ ] he's
saying
that it's more important that we focus
on violence against white people
than them gays that's what he's saying
let's listen so I don't know what the
definition of hate means but I would say
normally if you're killing somebody you
probably hate them I suppose they're
just some people who shoot into a crowd
or whatever
um oh
things causing Milwaukee which used to
be the safest of the twins anyone else
get the sense that this is just another
old [ __ ] white nut sack
when are they going to stop doing this
huh
I mean he's like the cookie cutter image
if if Trump was going to put out an nft
of a of a of an old white cracker ball
sack Republican this would be the guy
this would be the image well I mean it
would be uh you know he would have a
really muscular body and he would like
have a [ __ ] Cape he'd be like coming
down from heaven on a horse with this
guy stupid [ __ ] head but you know
that's that's how they do these nfts
that's how they do their digital artwork
now but let's listen my biggest cities
in this country uh become such a here he
goes dangerous and here's he goes with
the conflation and I think uh one if we
look at the type of people coming in the
crimes the breakdown of the family and
of course he means black people that's
what he means Gabe Sanchez he means
black people that's what he means he's
like oh you know the people who you know
their fathers are in jail and and black
people is what he means let's continue
people here who stood with the black
lives matter
uh was opposed to that secondly we have
the police hatred I think that's even
more than the okay I can't I can't take
it anymore of course he's conflating all
these issues black lives matter he's
like oh the family breakdown I'm black
lives matter what well that's what he
means also the way that he's like yeah
so we're just here we're talking about
my lives matter like the fact that you
can like you watch this guy say this
right just in the most like
calm I want when I when I say calm I
mean just like just kind of like
straight just like no inflection he's
just like so uh yeah basically I'm a
[ __ ] racist and uh I'm a piece of
[ __ ] but I'm just here to waste people's
time and talk about something that isn't
really a thing but I figured I might as
well give myself a soapbox to talk on
because I'm a fragile white mine with a
little dick
right like that
that's honestly that's a perfect
that's a perfect impersonation of of uh
grothman here yeah and I like I said
Hoffman more like Grossman yeah go out
of here bro guys gross listen don't you
get the sense that they literally would
make an nft of Grossman here just
because of his little views on well you
know violence against LGBT people yeah
some people will go in and shoot them up
with a weapon but the real problem is
black people like that's the real bro
like that's literally what he did that's
it really they would make a really
shitty nft of him right yeah did you
hear my description of him coming down
from the heavens yeah I did I did that's
pretty accurate yeah that's exactly how
they would I mean if I was gonna order
if I was gonna go to Fiverr and order an
nft for for Grossman here and I was
gonna get like the lowest lowest bid
that I possibly could find I mean I'm
talking like 250 for that [ __ ] I
was gonna make a Fiverr joke this
morning but then I was like ah but at
the same time like I don't want to [ __ ]
on Fiverr because I honestly think the
quality of fiber is better but I
understand because I honestly at the
same thought as a designer I had [ __ ]
second hand like embarrassment from what
from looking at these like oh these are
shitty like it's almost as if they took
a photo and they're like all right cool
we'll just throw we'll just throw the
face up oh here I won't I don't want to
ruin it because I know we'll probably
get into and the [ __ ] let's round up oh
we're in the [ __ ] list baby all right
then let me let me get down on this [ __ ]
all right so he's got these [ __ ]
faces right
somebody is it all the same face no no
no he's got one where he's like winking
he's got one oh he's like looking he
said there's a couple different yeah but
the different emotions here [ __ ]
they're all the same [ __ ] face in a
way so basically what this is is this
reminds me
of all right this is this is what this
is It's a combination of somebody
throwing on a face of Donald Trump into
an image but at the same time it also
reminds me of [ __ ] AI art
because this uh yeah everyone's been
posting that what is that what is the
air I I haven't really done this yet
I've seen a lot of people post like oh
mine looks mine looks better than this
right yeah you know so it's just people
are a lot of people are using lensa but
the problem with lensa is that it's also
it's basically taking actual artist's
work and it's using AI to put you in
that image so it's also like there's a
bunch of people who have complaints
about like the you can still kind of see
signatures of the actual artists down
there but then they try to blur it out
there's a whole thing in how how it's
kind of unfair to the original artist
but that's what that's what's going on
and this is what this reminds me of they
took an image of Donald Trump and threw
it into a shitty Ai and then said boom
poop it out and then it literally [ __ ]
it out well so this one here okay
obviously he's a cowboy Donald Trump
would never ever be in an outfit like
this ever now I know what I know the
image that they're trying to project
here when I was a kid my grandpa loved
John Wayne yeah did you have anyone in
your family that watched John Wayne
movies like they were they were like
religious about it like my grandpa owned
he had a whole shelf with the VHS do you
remember what vhs's VHS John Wayne Right
everything he did he had all the [ __ ]
movies and he watched them all the time
that's what this is this is this is
Donald Trump pretending
in the digital space to be John Wayne
because he can't do it in real life like
like can you imagine Trump dressing up
like this and trying to look like this
like number one come on man that would
be hilarious you know what you know it's
a great idea and maybe I shouldn't say
it out loud and you know whatever
um we should we should actually do the
images of what he'd actually look like
if he was if he was dressed up that
would be something I would pay someone
on Fiverr for sure yeah right I would be
like hey you pay him good money yeah
because I want to clear something up
about the Fiverr thing because I made
the Fiverr joke I made the Viber joke
this morning yeah but here's here's what
I'll say fiber is is kind of a a complex
world because there are very good very
professional artists on there right
that's yeah they they are there to
provide you with a a very very good
service we use them a lot yeah it was
for some of our graphics and some other
things but
even some of our merch Graphics we've
we've had fiber artists help us on some
of those things but here's the thing
there's some of the people on there that
are just like look I'm just cranking
stuff out you pay me three or four
dollars I'll crank something out for you
you know what I mean like three dollars
goes a lot further other parts of the
world and they just want your three
bucks and they'll crank out something
yeah right and this really like you're
saying this is kind of what this is so
that this is the John Wayne one all
right which again why don't you you know
what you should do here because I want
to break this down for people can you go
to the actual website
yeah I can yeah yeah because you know
what these images don't do it quite just
as what I'm about to reveal okay so
let's let's do this first because the
first thing I want to play is the info
yesterday we well yesterday we played
the trailer
yeah well I wanna I wanna play this
scissor reel yeah right yes this is a
real right well that's what it is right
what else are you gonna call that
[ __ ] yeah I mean yeah it's a
Sizzle I mean
it kind of you know like you know when
you're making pancakes you know how to
test the pan for pancakes right
[Music]
okay I'm at the right temperature I can
pour my battery that's that's the sizzle
that we're going for here yeah yeah it's
a bare minimum right here is here's the
um the announcement of the announcement
yesterday now let's watch this America
needs a superhero superheroes
foreign
[Music]
of course yesterday everyone's like what
the hell is this announcement a VP or is
he gonna is he gonna go to Russia I mean
it was all guys we gave him what way way
way way God too much credit it's the
same thing when I thought Elon Musk
would back out of the Twitter deal I'm
like no way he's gonna do this yep he
did it and he's it's a [ __ ] disaster
same thing here now here so here is
let's go to the next this morning yes
um the actual uh yeah announcement so so
did he because I'm unsure of this did he
release
did he release the the actual
infomercial that you're talking about
first or did he do the true social no no
he did the true social you can't the
infomercial is on the website so we have
to go to the website to watch it I mean
there's also people who repost it on
Twitter I got it here's here's the
announcement though if I can [ __ ]
there we go okay so this is his post
about it on fraud social what the major
announcement is and really it's going
over like a wet fart in a white thong
here oh yeah uh I mean it's it's
horrible
um major announcement my official Donald
Trump digital trading card I can't even
believe I can't even [ __ ] believe a
former president is typing this out on
his [ __ ] social media yeah
this is so [ __ ] dumb
uh the collection is here these limited
edition cards feature amazing art
because he's got a capitalize of my life
and career and life and career are
capital I don't understand that [ __ ] uh
collect all your favorite Trump digital
trading cards
very much like baseball card baseball
card just one just one right I mean we
very much like uh like AP Yeah well yeah
but hopefully much more exciting uh go
to this website and get your cards now
this is the best part only only
99
each not for the whole [ __ ]
collection each
that would make a great Christmas gift I
mean gift don't wait it's the other best
part I mean this is really the cherry on
top they will be gone I believe very
quickly
um
as if a digital image
well he means by that is because it's
you can have a limited amount of them
you can say like there's only 10 in
circulation that's not to say that
people goodness but see that's the thing
though we talked about this with Anthony
scaramucci back in March remember and
you kind of challenged him a little bit
and he was trying to say oh well there's
signatures embedded on the image and
you're like yeah but who gives a [ __ ]
yeah like who's going who's going to
look at the [ __ ] signature on the
image yeah it's like the board ape
collection the problem with images like
nfts have a right-click problem meaning
that you right click and you save it now
yeah you could have the digital footpr
or the thumb print on there that says
like it's based on you know it's it's uh
this is authentic it's authentic and
it's combined it's on the blockchain
ethereum like you could do it that way
sure
I kind of feel like it was but who would
give a [ __ ] but who would give a [ __ ]
exactly and and the problem here is that
uh
uh also this isn't something that you'd
be like oh man I'm the proud owner of a
trump trading card now there are
certainly people for sure within the
cult that would [ __ ] say that but
also you have to think of the people who
are in that group now there's a bunch of
like [ __ ] libertarian uh crypto Bros
and all the [ __ ] in the Republican party
as well
but all these people are [ __ ] idiots
right they're all the ones who are like
in the [ __ ] FTX [ __ ] with it's just
it's just insane seems like FTX has been
in the news I I'm just saying here
here's the the infomercial okay on and I
guess this is ripped off the website but
let's let's take a look at why you
should consider
um these as the Christmas gift a gift
yeah for 99 bucks each
hello everyone this is Donald Trump
hopefully your favorite President of all
time better than Lincoln better than
what I get it I gotta stop it right
there hopefully I'm your favorite
President hopefully yeah
hopefully I mean I know I know I know
you you are kind of getting soft on me
and everything but hopefully I'm still
your favorite better than Lincoln and
better than Washington better than
Lincoln better than Washington
uh check out these nfts they're like a
baseball okay yeah I get it okay let's
keep going if we can Washington with an
important announcement to make I'm doing
my first official Donald J Trump nft
collection right here and right now
they're called Trump digital trading
cards these cards feature some of the
really incredible okay stop here if
you're looking at this image if you're
looking at this image it literally is
him trying to be Joe Biden in a [ __ ]
astronauts costume it's right he's
literally got the the aviators on which
he's never wore ever and never seen him
in a pair of aviators he's trying to do
the whole Joe Biden dark Brandon thing
I'm Joe Biden
uh it really is it is so funny that he
tries so hard I mean not only one again
all of these [ __ ] cards and we'll
we'll show them in a minute once we
finish this little [ __ ] video but the
goddamn photoshop on all of these it's
horrible horrendous it's horrible so
here's here's the deal and I said this
in the first 30 minutes and maybe you
will agree with me on this this seems
like the all the doing of Nick Adams
like all of it like probably he came up
with the idea he's like oh this will be
so uh we'll put you in an astronaut
costume it'll be so you will look so
manly you're gonna be an alpha Mr
President like don't you see it actually
probably you're gonna be an alpha Mr
President well you're gonna be an alpha
it's all yeah he's like
it's like I'm I'm Nick Adams and uh oh
yeah you know and then he's yeah he's
got a whole thing he's like I love
[ __ ] Trump oh let me Gaggle on these
balls
just like
um
my name's Nick Adams and I [ __ ] love
this car
s oh these mushroom dick here
we're supposed to have Dr Rachel
benagoffer on to show us how to mock
these [ __ ] today that's why and and
Gabe Sanchez is doing a master class
that's called him cooking balls here God
damn hey I'll go down end on this man
right hi my name's my name's Nick Adams
and I will definitely go down under on
Trump like that's that is the that is
the fat fat [ __ ] cuck right there
believe me when I say I'm in Alpha
because Alphas don't have to say that
they're out yeah Alphas don't have to
say that keep in mind the guy's saying
that puts it in a [ __ ] parenthesis
Nick Adams alpha male like it's almost
just it's uh okay you know what just
keep going keep going I keep cutting
these balls here okay let's let's see if
we can get through this oh [ __ ]
incredible artwork pertaining to my life
and my career it's been very exciting
you can collect your Trump digital cards
just like a baseball card or other
Collectibles here's one of the best
parts each card comes with an automatic
chance to win amazing prizes like dinner
with me I don't know if that's an
amazing prize
my God what he said right there because
I wrote it down and I I've been meaning
to tweet this he said each card comes
with an automatic chance to win an
amazing to win uh okay each card comes
with an automatic chance to win amazing
prizes like dinner with me I don't know
if that that's an amazing prize but it's
what we have
the idea where he's like oh look guys uh
we got some crazy good prizes maybe you
think it's good I don't know I mean like
you're gonna have dinner with me I
really need people to have dinner with
me it would be awesome if you could have
dinner with me I don't know maybe like
you guys want to I don't know you know
it look please just have dinner with me
pay 99
to win a chance to have dinner with me
oh they're gonna pay way more 99 if
anyone's buying these they're buying
them all dude they're going to go to
their equity line on their mortgage
they're gonna they're gonna go to credit
cards that they have to buy every single
one of these that's what they're gonna
do I also don't know who these people
are like who's the guy in the left and
who's the woman on the right I have no
idea but they're [ __ ] I I honestly I
don't see the dude's hands so definitely
a hand check there
right hand up like this so I wonder
where the left hand is meanwhile Trump
is like I wish Nick Adams under the
table
and
and I want to point out that his hand no
matter what perspective you put it in is
not that big no [ __ ] way okay let's
let's see it's it's kind of tiny okay
let's see if we can work we got all over
a minute left I don't know if we're
gonna make it through this or golf with
you and a group of your friends at one
of my beautiful golf courses and they
are beautiful I'm also doing Zoom calls
a one-on-one meeting autographing
memorabilia and so much more we're doing
a lot of my official Trump digital
trading cards are 99 which doesn't it
feels like it feels like he's riding a
[ __ ] elephant it feels like they just
came up with this yesterday oh yeah no
they didn't work sure they didn't
Workshop or Wordsmith any of this [ __ ]
man they didn't get he's just off the
cuff dude yesterday Nick Adams was there
coddling his balls and they're like yeah
let's do this nft thing and he's like
well let's record something and he's
standing there and he just says this
dumb [ __ ] and now they're like well wait
a second we have to [ __ ] come up with
prizes now he's like yes prices there
will be prizes and they have no [ __ ]
clue they're like what what prizes
you're gonna go eat dinner what the [ __ ]
is this [ __ ] like literally this is such
a [ __ ] joke and this is their
presumptive nominee folks yeah this is a
for Jimmy Carter has habit the
[ __ ] builds houses with his
hands
for poor people he builds houses with
his he's in his 90s
Bill Clinton and the Clinton Foundation
Barack Obama produces some of the best
documentaries that we've seen
and this [ __ ] is putting out
half-assed fiber baseball cards digital
bait are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me this is
the best a major announcement he can do
are you [ __ ] kid what kind of [ __ ]
joke is this let's continue I can't I
can't even believe I got to do this
today but it's hilarious you sound like
very much for what you're getting buy
one and you will join a very exclusive
Community it's my community oh Jesus and
I think it's something you're going to
like and you're going to like it a lot
they also make perfect gifts so you can
buy them with your credit card or a
perfect Crypt it's a perfect gift okay I
can't anymore I can't anymore listen
we've got we've got Dr Rachel bittickoff
for joining us and I'm gonna we're gonna
get her opinion and then we'll go to the
website and I guess do the expert
analysis of the shitty horrible
Photoshop I will reveal you something
that is both surprising and not
surprising at the same time and it's
it's um we're it's a q Anon World we're
just living in Dr Rachel binikoffer how
are you my friend dude I think Gabe just
nailed that right it's the perfect grift
for Christmas dude it is a Christmas
gift isn't it oh my God see I was busy
this morning so I missed all of this and
I was in a meeting and someone mentioned
it
um
let's say I was a little late to the
waiting room because I got destroyed
yes ridiculous yesterday when he said
there was going to be a major
announcement
Rachel I thought maybe he was going to
announce that he was changing uh adult
diaper Brands I really thought maybe
that was gonna what it was gonna be and
really to me that was like Ah that's
that's [ __ ] that's that there's no
way that's gonna happen what a joke that
in this way worse it's way worse than if
he was count to come out or go on true
social be like hey I know I I had it for
Depends and Depends has been dependable
for me for years and catching and
catching those wet farts but today I'm
announcing I'm moving to a different
brand because depends is woke they're
just woke over there
literally I could see that as not as
much of a joke as what this is how in
the [ __ ] are we even here how the [ __ ]
are we getting here yeah it's [ __ ]
surreal right I mean yeah you ever nail
in it you almost felt bad I almost
wanted to leave the waiting room just
let you continue uh your your Epic
he's a former president and he builds
houses he he formed an entire [ __ ]
organization that builds houses for
people who can't afford houses right and
he goes to these places and he's been
doing it for years he's throwing the
hammer even now and not only right but
they're you know they were like all
right you got to give up The Peanut Farm
and he's like real the peanuts really
the [ __ ] peanuts and they're like all
right fine I'll do that and then you got
Trump and he's like I won't [ __ ] put
my name off of any of these properties I
will remove myself I won't put an
independent fund I won't do anything
that removes myself from any sort of
insight into something I can make money
off and it just continues you gotta
every single time is a grift there I
mean here we gave him too much credit we
thought it was going to be some big
announcement because he said it was
we're like oh okay
I mean you were at the iron alone okay
everybody thought that it was going to
be something speaker of the house
um maybe maybe if it was disappointing
in in its severity like Kerry Lake
running with her whatever right if it
was going to be disappointing though in
scope like not like this okay
so the the fan is I was really looking
at just Ron phillipowski's tweet just
now before I came in I might have said
that wrong and was certainly did because
I'm shitty at pronunciation
um I think he was he was putting in
screenshots of all these trumpers who
were devastated they're like wait a
minute he promised us a major right I
mean they all look like the [ __ ] wife
on a Christmas story when the leg lamp
pops out of the [ __ ] box
you know and I just think uh I just
think we're it's gonna be a good year
I don't like to Pat myself on the back
that much just every day every once in a
while you know we and I do a lot of Bank
batting here myself but I really want to
give myself credit here I've been saying
for two damn years that we are at the
intersection this is how I say it we are
at the intersection of WrestleMania and
real life and this [ __ ] delivers
for me this morning with this image of
him in a [ __ ] wrestling belt in a
wrestling ring are you [ __ ] me has
he been listening to my show
I am gonna need somebody who's talented
at dige whatever and is nft just before
whatever no don't get into that whoever
can do this [ __ ] better mock the [ __ ]
out of it so let's talk about that
because Rachel I was I was gonna bring
you on because yesterday
um Ron DeSantis uh it showed in some
stupid poll which probably doesn't
[ __ ] make a hell beans worth the
difference at this point but we should
use it as a cudjoe and a wedge between
these idiots where Ron DeSantis is up 30
points on Trump right and I believe it
was a USA date today poll and I wanted
to bring you on because I wanted you to
tell the audience of how we actually use
that as a wedge right because I think
people are confused about him running
for president he's actually running for
the Republican nomination right yes and
it is our job to make sure we make all
them run against Trump and Trump run
against them right yeah he's gonna be
the Democratic nominee yes we want to
encourage as much of this Civil War and
in party suspicion and fighting and
dysfunction is possible because we're
trying to we're trying to find like this
has been a process Republicans have been
in really now over a decade okay and
there's been fits and starts in this
process where you know tea party Rises
becomes huge faction then it becomes the
center of gravity and now it's [ __ ]
in control right it calls itself other
things but it's the same movement so
it's totally Consolidated its power now
and um you know we are we have a really
unique opportunity I think because of
Trump's legal woes and weakness as in
Jan six and all the baggage he would
bring his refusal not to not announce
because remember the party asked him to
not announce and even told him if you do
announce we're not going to pay your
legal fees anymore because they
understood how bad capitalized he is for
them he's a [ __ ] Albatross hanging
around their necks right so the more
that we can amplify Rhonda sanus right
now and play DeSantis off of term and
vice versa that's going to help us the
more that we seed you know anger with
Trump and the rest of the Republican
party that's going to help us because
what we really want to do is use our own
strategic outrage strategic mocking
whatever to amplify the division within
the Republican party and see if we can
force it into having finally this full
meltdown crisis that it really needs to
have if American democracy is going to
stabilize again well and he delivers the
perfect gift this morning with this
because because and you I think you
tweeted
it was this week or over the weekend you
said look you need to mock them at every
single moment it has to be all mockery
with and we call it the [ __ ] committees
here um they're going to have the [ __ ]
committees for the hunter Biden's laptop
they're going to have the [ __ ] committee
I like it yeah they're gonna have the
[ __ ] committees in the house
um and we gotta mock every single every
single presser they do every single
statement they put out every single
tweet they tweet we have to mock them at
every turn and we have to be laughing at
them and the entire country will turn
and laugh at them as well yes and if
they are seen as jokes jokes don't get
elected ask Harry Lee just ask Carrie
Lake Blake Masters if
jokes do not get elected ursul Walker
right right
so if we can do that so what what what
should we do in this because again Joe
Biden is going to be the Democratic
nominee we don't have to worry about
that he's he's one of the most effective
presidents of our lifetimes and he's
going to be the nominee there's no one
going to challenge him there's no reason
to even consider or talk about or or
even have any kind of narrative
messaging around that yes what what I
what I want to focus on is how how do we
in this Republican primary because
that's the election we really want to
focus on drawing these wedges and
mocking the [ __ ] out of them and as much
attention too because because normal
humans won't watch that [ __ ] show so we
have to bring out the [ __ ] show and
enforce them to look
well and I've I've said this uh in the
first half hour is the Republican
parties in general in the last 30 years
really has been experts at this right I
mean they've done this and they've
they've mocked us they make they make us
look like a bunch of clowns yep and it's
because they are the rodeo clowns they
have their circus and I have always
argued and that's what the show is about
from the beginning is we need to have
our own circus our own clown show to
bring attention to this to say hey look
at these crazies over here right and
make sure that the crazies over here are
all Republicans everywhere if you're in
our next your name or you're voting for
an R you're a joke it's all it's all
craziness it's joke you're carry Lake
your Blake Masters your Dr Oz you're
Donald Trump that's what you are right I
don't care if your name is Rhonda real
quick on that Tony because like what you
want to do with folks is you don't want
to make them feel stupid you want to
make them feel like if they
that's a really important Nuance go on
well and and so tell us about that tell
us what we do I mean what do we do in
our because we we have microphones right
so we are going to be able to have this
National narrative a little different
than than the average people walking
around talking to people they know so
what do those people do to mock them and
because that's really what pushes The
Narrative it's right it's the people
it's the people out there talking to
people about these issues so what do
they do what does the audience do to
mock them that is most effective I mean
the so here's the thing with mocking
guys I mean I don't think every human
being is going to be cut out to do some
mocking right but I think there's
degrees of mocking that that with
different degrees of comfortability okay
because here's here's the secret core of
mocking for a successful mock to work it
should hit the persons it should be
strategically designed to exploit the
person's greatest strength and turn it
into a liability right so sometimes that
means you have to pick on someone's
appearance or whatever right
um you know we mocking is mean
inherently mean right and you know oh we
don't want to make fun of older people
ageism you know whatever I get that I
understand that 100 but we're looking at
[ __ ] gulags in the future so I'm just
gonna have to do what has to be done
right they're gonna mock us and we're
gonna mock them and what we're going to
do is we're going to look for their most
proudest element like so Marjorie Taylor
green what's she super focused on her
[ __ ] self she doesn't care about
anything else and where she's super
focused on her appearance her
physicality and her exercise crap right
so if I'm in a mock MTG I'm not gonna
mock her for being stupid I'm gonna mock
her on that space that she considers
where she where she is most likely to
get upset by the mock right
um Rhonda Santos the thing that he's the
most afraid of is being called dumb
right he he doesn't want to look stupid
at all so you have to mock DeSantis on
that on that element right
um so there's there's different
approaches for different folks and
there's different levels to do it but if
you can't do like the personal like Matt
Gates has a squirrel living in his hair
we should investigate that maybe we
should use gloves if you can't do [ __ ]
like that the other way to mock them is
to mock their premises okay so like
they're making these arguments and our
instinct is to be like well that's
stupid because Republicans did this or
that or this is that or you know Jared
Kushner has two billion dollars and as
you have done with your cup committee or
cup committee label right because of
course who's going to chair a committee
more than Jim Jordan right he's gonna be
like oh I want that [ __ ] job come on
right so you know what you've done is
you've undermined the entire premise
right and so we really want to be doing
that in all things coming forward
whether it's fallacy foxy or
um you know Biden or hunter or or the
Homeland Security Department guy instead
of talking about well we didn't you know
this is happening at immigration or that
in other words complex we got Refuge we
need to make [ __ ] fun of them we need
to be like you know um find find an
element about you know uh Republicans in
Immigration and just just make fun of
them you know and it's really difficult
because we want to respond substantively
but as soon as we do as soon as you are
doing that you have legitimated they're
crazy right so like right now we're
seeing this process play out in the
media where Sunday shows and other
things like CNN not MSNBC when I [ __ ]
about the media guys just know I'm not
bitching about MSNBC if everybody
[ __ ] covered [ __ ] like MSNBC we
wouldn't be on the cross accustomed
Democratic collapse so the media system
no one wants us MSNBC no one basically
so I'm talking about the rest of the
system and they're already serving to
legitimate it because they'll say Well
when House Republicans take power they
have plans to investigate Biden and
they're not saying and they have no
basis for any of these investigations
these are complete fake political like
attempts to harass political enemies
they're literally using the government
to do the thing that they purport to be
the most afraid about with the
government which is using the government
to come after private individuals right
so um we can't win on substance we
cannot win on on um you know going
toe-to-toe or you know reminding other
people about Kushner
the only way that we can save the
narrative is to re is just to hit right
at the basis and make fun of them for
you know investigating that they want to
investigate penises and stuff right you
have to you have to mitigate the
um the seriousness if we buy into the
seriousness with our own seriousness
then we have done their work for them
and we really must avoid that well you
know the easiest part
is we got chuckleheads like this yeah I
mean it's it's yeah it's I mean it's
very easy when they when they parody
serve it up
it's ridiculous but you know they are
ridiculous right and that's what we
should be pointing out and we should
continue to push
um The Narrative that these people again
they're jokes and I think that's what I
tweeted this morning but I I want to go
back to something you said because you
tweeted this the other day
um and I think this is a very uh easy
way for people to wrap their head around
that the difference in narratives right
and the difference of messaging like
even when you're talking to someone and
they bring up the investigations that
the Republicans are going to do you
don't refer to them as the investigation
you say you mean the Sham investigations
the Sham investigations you never not
have a descriptive word that mocks the
investigation that they're talking about
um again that's mocking that's an easy
way to mock the investigation it's
called a sham now I call it the [ __ ]
committee right that's that's a I think
someone put it in our chat they said
[ __ ] committee and so I I was like okay
from now on hence Court there is going
to be known as the car committee here on
my show but the chant you called it the
Sham investigation in your Tweet
um and and I think that is a good way to
wrap your head an easy way to understand
exactly what narrative and messaging is
without getting into this whole you know
because I know you're a professor so you
could teach a class on this right but
the easiest way is to say instead of
saying and giving them credibility by
saying the investigations you say the
Sham investigations and you know what
it's crazy about that Rachel is
Republicans have been doing that for
years yes yes years over real [ __ ]
overreal right okay right so like you
know I think I go on to Sam you know the
reason that 50 of the country is in a
math psychosis event is that every one
of them every [ __ ] time from McCarthy
down to MTG never said investigation
they always said uh you know Witch Hunt
or sham invest on whatever the word
whichever investigation from Russia gate
to the Ukraine Scandal to the you know
Jan sick [ __ ] and after they they always
across their whole system they're
activists their you know Grassroots
their ditch comes everyone always brands
or frames the investigation as as
illegitimate and we must do the same and
I and and really the sad plate thing is
the people we need the most to do that
are the reporters out there who are
going to be covering these stories
because when they put out their copy
it's almost certain to say the house
gobs investigation and it is not going
to to fix that premise issue for us it's
going to legitimate these investigations
which are all illegitimate there is no
legitimate basis to investigate any of
the people that they want to investigate
for any of the things that they want to
investigate right it is literally the
opposite of how oversight's supposed to
be done you're supposed to have a fire
and find out what caused it not go and
look for for smoke and a fire with an
investigation it is the weaponization of
our investigative uh process so our only
hope though is to make sure that our
voices whether you're just Tweeter and
you're watching the show and you tweet
or you run [ __ ] or you're an activist or
whatever
you cannot accept the premise that these
investigations are anything but fake I
agree with you and I think we need to
press the the media in this country to
get them in a situation where they can
say in a headline sham investigation as
opposed to investigation
um doctor that's I mean that's that's
all you can say that that is what the
Republican party is it's Shams and scams
and everything
and folks out there go follow Rachel on
Twitter she's gonna be there until that
sumbitch dies
um and she will be posting what you're
supposed to be doing with messaging and
narrative every single time that she
posts
um she always and I try to find him and
retweet them and so everyone has them
because Tony can I just say too have you
guys noticed all the Elon likes
um psychops stuff I'm doing on Elon
going out for Tesla going after Tesla's
dog talking about hostile takeovers
that's a good point and because a lot of
people don't think that the Elon Twitter
thing has anything to do with politics
but it has everything to do with it gosh
everything yeah so I appreciate you
being here and thanks for giving us
insight into the into driving wedges
into the Republican party and making
sure that we keep our narrative and our
messaging going from 2022 continuing it
making sure it's better for 2024 so we
can finally maybe dunk these and 86
these fascists into history I don't
think they're going to go away that
easily but um every every the next
election is always the most important
election in our democracy's lifetime at
this point in history well you know what
you say what they say what I say Tony
right which is when they go low we grab
them by the nuts and squeeze right and
right now these people are on their
their heels so it's it's full [ __ ]
ahead often everybody well one more
question
um yes or no before we go I want the
audience to know does Kevin McCarthy get
218.
I think he's going to have to trade away
this incredibly important power that was
put into the Republican speakership
after John Boehner was forced to take
his own Immigration Reform Bill in 2013
and that was at that time the house
caucus could call a vote of no
confidence basically for the speaker at
any time when Paul Ryan was literally
forced into taking Boehner's role as
Speaker he would not do it unless they
got rid of that so they did get rid of
it and what the house Freedom caucus
America first mega nuts are demanding
for McCarthy for that 218 is a return of
that and I think that's that ultimately
is what we'll end up seeing happen but I
by no means would put a high probability
on it I am not in other words I'm not a
hundred percent confident we won't just
see a January where they can't even find
a speaker I think you're right because
every day to me
um it's it's like oh he's got 213 now
it's 2 15. now it's back to 214. you
might have 216 one hour and the next
hour it's different so I I I hope I hope
they keep infining and I hope they are
scrambling on the floor to find a
speaker and and they're having to do
everything they can and Kevin McCarthy
has to negotiate
um everything away uh for him to be
Speaker of the House never seen a
speaker come in or try to come in who
cannot cannot Advance the needs of his
Frontline majority maker members okay so
this is a completely unique situation
we've never seen anything like it and
yeah there is no man in America more
[ __ ] right now than Kevin McCarthy
that's great keep driving those wedges
and Dr Rachel bidicoff everyone will
follow her on Twitter thank you for
joining us my friend everyone stick
around we'll be right back with more
more trading cards drunk trading cards
right after these messages
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
Gabe Sanchez is one of the best shows
we've done in a long time here just you
can't it's laughing laughs all day long
it's off the expensive the Cheeto depths
q and honor self-inflicted mockery the
self-parody
um you wanted me to bring up the website
uh this uh Trump collects cards
something another I don't know
they actually you know the website
um looks better than the cards believe
it or not I don't know uh it does so
here's the website here
all right so I like the erection button
how it's like
yeah they should have a sound effect
s so if you
you go to trump card to collect
trumpcards.com I also tried to check
earlier if they owned collect trump card
uh it is owned by someone I oh okay
we're gonna try to NAB it I was gonna
try and NAB it so people went to it they
might get I don't know another image of
trump
um but
if somebody owns it so I couldn't I
couldn't do it but also they don't
redirect uh collecttrumpcard.com so it's
probably they don't own it you would
think you would think that would be one
yeah and you think that because that's
that's a you know that's an easy
misspelling when you're typing in the uh
the URL so I mean you know you think if
they did Own It they'd redirect that
would be
that would be smart of them which I mean
this is really stupid so maybe I'm
giving them too much credit again but
here's his website and literally it they
are 99 each
each holy no they they do own it oh they
just I just looked up the registration
information it's the same company I got
you perfect privacy LLC which means it's
basically you just clicked a button that
said uh that you could okay this is
created sorry side note this was created
the website was purchased in October
10 uh 10 1
20 20. so this has been in the works for
a little bit somebody bought it and was
like I got a great idea and then you
know they probably they probably went
down to Mar-A-Lago snuck in the gate you
know the gate where where you go in to
get your uh your look at the top secret
documents right yeah probably win in
that one sorry actually that was that
was sorry that was collect trumpcard.com
collect Trump uh sorry collect
trumpcards.com cards plural that's the
actual website the actual website was
created on 7 26 2022 and was updated so
basically it's been live possibly since
10 18 2022 but nobody knew obviously to
look for because nobody would have
expected a [ __ ] former president to
release a bunch of digital trading cards
right no one had that in their bingo
well you know now that you're saying all
this it feels like
um there's something too someone did
this and then went down to convince him
to buy into this right and to do this
it's quite possible that somebody did
that so all right so this is what I want
to separate a little stop right there
okay sweepstakes bonus right
this is the one in the video where he's
he's ad-libbing this he's like yeah
we're gonna have great sweepstakes right
and he starts and he doesn't and it's
not they didn't have this probably when
he did the video right probably he's
like oh I don't know okay so here's
here's the thing that I'm pretty sure is
illegal
illegal you said like criminal or just
against no like criminal well yeah I
mean I'm sure somebody sued they might
have a case should I should I message
Ben mine's Ellis and see if we can get a
yeah sorry so uh sweepstakes bonus right
he's he keeps talking about these
sweepstakes enter the sweepstakes enter
the sweepstakes okay this is where you
buy it and they're gonna draw your name
out of the right right okay so with
every Digital Collection or collectible
you buy you're entered into the Trump
sweepstakes which sounds like [ __ ]
hell
thousands of prizes see below for
thousands thousands all right so go down
okay here we go so is this where the uh
oh this is the actual image these are
the images
so you get a Miami dinner with Donald
Trump why does it say win on every one
of these is that because you're gonna
win a sweepstakes yeah I don't think you
could win one of them you know here's
the space man one Mar-A-Lago group
cocktail hour
let's see if I can zoom in here there's
the spaceman one
they want to be dark Brandon if I don't
know if you can see this but like the
shoulders don't even really kind of yeah
no it's a terrible job it is a [ __ ]
because this is like a 3D image you know
it's got some Dimension to it yeah but
the image of his head doesn't have much
there's not it doesn't look like it's in
the helmet it looks like it's a sticker
on the front of the helmet yeah they
took uh they took some images and just
threw them in there oh and then you got
Trump gold bars and it's a notice notice
how the hands are extra large oh yeah
those are the the proportions exactly
what this is exactly what Rachel
minnicoffer was talking about right like
when you make fun of his time because
that bothers the ever loving [ __ ] out of
here yeah and you can tell just in this
image here where they made his hands
extremely large that that [ __ ] bothers
him
and again he is there is never it's been
a long time since Donald Trump has fit
in a suit like this that's gonna say
this is the [ __ ] not I mean if you
compare this is an actual foot of him
golfing if you were to look at that one
versus the other one it's like there's a
but there's like a couple there's like
two less chins and uh he could actually
fit I wouldn't be surprised if they were
like let me slim down the arms here
because he def this is in his like elbow
it's like you've got that muscle
definition
there's no way that he [ __ ] has that
you know what's funny about that image
because if you go back here it says 45
see this on yeah because he was he was
he was the 45th president with an
Asterix next to it right and then in
this one it says 47.
so he's already he's already selling
[ __ ] as if he's the 47th president of
the United States it's just [ __ ] it's
weird [ __ ] hilarious so then you go
down which one do you see oh you get a
zoo he looks dude the aviators on this
make him look like a goddamn bug he
looks like a fly right that's true and
he's trying to do
he's trying to do the whole Joe Biden
thing what the [ __ ] oh he's trying to be
as cool as dark Brandon here that's you
know what this is that is exactly what
we did to him when when when the
internet as a collective did the whole
dark Brandon thing that's probably where
this derived from he's like whoa there's
way more cool images of Joe Biden out
there than there are of me I'm gonna I'm
gonna make some really cool images where
I look really really Alpha and I'm gonna
sell them for 99 each and he looks like
the movie The Fly can you zoom in a
little bit can you zoom in that's as far
as I get oh okay well all right so if
you right uh I'm not saying look at his
dick but I am saying uh he's got a
little dick
anyway move over to the football one
okay here's the here he is on the 45
yard line with the 45 hat and holding a
45 football okay the Hat doesn't even
it's supposed to be a ball cap but it
almost looks like a really stupid Beanie
doesn't it at first like when you first
look it does yeah I mean like again you
know they're taking his they're taking
his body the other thing too is they
could have potentially done a whole
photo shoot with Trump and they're like
do this pose do this pose and then
they're like all right we're just gonna
manipulate these other things or what
they said is great we're gonna take
photos with another person's body
because we know that he couldn't fit in
the suit no [ __ ] we know it wouldn't be
this slim no so clearly what they
probably did was they took a photo with
another model and said all right that's
like a Slimmer version we'll go with
that then they took a bunch of images of
his face and said all right we're gonna
do this and then they're like all right
we're gonna do a little bit of digital
manipulation we might do some AR AI art
here we might do like some some more
kind of uh digital renderings to it to
make it seem a little surreal in its
appearance because it's just [ __ ]
fake
um
because everything is just like a shitty
photo it is but here's I want to point
out a few things number one again the
hands are massive like yeah if you were
if you were gonna do like art like like
scaling you're like whoa those hands are
way too big to be realistic right so
they're massive the other thing too that
is telling in this one and I don't know
if you like personally approved these or
not I doubt it but
you know where's the red tie really long
and that's a trick I don't know if
anyone knows everything Donald Trump
does with his costume because it truly
is he is in drag when he's doing these
things his tie he ties his tie really
long and the reason why is so he looks
taller right if your tie is longer you
it well also it's it's not only that but
it also covers his stomach right so by
doing it because it gets the tie
literally they're [ __ ] fat ties
they're right they're like the the width
or yeah the width of like a [ __ ]
cummerbund they're that [ __ ] thick
but in this image here that tie is not
as long as Donald Trump wears it no no
no not even it's it's definitely past
his pants and the hat I can't get over
the Hat it looks so this is great now we
get into some [ __ ] uh Talladega
Nights [ __ ] whoa [ __ ] look at the Hat on
this one this is even this doesn't even
look dude this is what the this photo is
his presidential photo
whoa whoa whoa so they're they're doing
what we do every day with a thumbnail
they're just grabbing images off Google
they threw on they were like great we
got an image of somebody's body Doom
done and then they just threw on his
face I mean the [ __ ] the proportions
aren't right the angle isn't right his
neck is way slimmer that's his photo if
you want to look this up this is a
[ __ ] photo from his presidential
photo go look it up online
literally it's the same one he probably
has a picture and they could have took a
picture with him wearing yeah yeah this
hat or a hat but the other thing I want
to point out again he's got 47 on this
one this one was 45. now he's over here
claiming he's 47. here's here's one
where he's in the boxing ring right yeah
um and he's got 45 on this one H hey my
name's Donald Trump
is that the same [ __ ] that is this
they're just putting different arms on
this yeah you see that look at the
shoulders there that is literally you
know that is what they're doing they are
putting different arms on this they
might they might honestly also have uh
just like all right we got the arms we
got the body we got the legs throw in
the head and it goes behind the the neck
of the shirt
crazy [ __ ] okay let's see if we can get
some um that's it so that's that's it
right now so so remember remember what
we showed you they said so there's an
order to win or an end sorry in order to
get into the sweepstakes Right
sweepstakes You Gotta Buy right
scroll down
well actually go to go to how to go to
how to
how it works all right so they tell you
how to store your your trump card right
you get your email but you gotta
purchase
select how many as if people wanted more
than one but whatever can you understand
how digital file works there chummy okay
so then once you do that receive your
you receive your cards and you enter
your chance to win by getting these uh
Sweepstake codes okay so they they told
you now so it's a code yeah yeah because
it's your chance then you enter the code
I think all right so now that you're
entered in the sweepstakes you buy it
because you're probably not
automatically entered in this week no no
no you have to opt in right because
that's the whole [ __ ] game you have
to buy it and then opt in so here's the
thing
you purchase you get a chance to enter
into the sweepstakes right now scroll
down to the bottom of the page and hit
uh uh go keep going keep going keep
going keep going that's all right
official rules go to official rules Now
official rules okay here we are
what is the first line under official
rules okay it says official Donald Trump
nft collection sweepstakes
official rules no purchase necessary to
enter to what the [ __ ]
uh no I haven't seen anyone but I
haven't seen anyone really enter or win
meaning meaning
um you don't have to purchase these
things to get in the sweepstakes are we
going to enter the sweepstakes
well you can't enter the sweepstakes
because you'd have to purchase a [ __ ]
card ticket yeah but it says it says
right here Sanchez it says right here
let me highlight it no purchase
necessary to enter or win okay so how do
we get the code I want the code because
I don't know why I want to enter the
sweepstakes I want to go to Mar-A-Lago
and meet Donald Trump I want to be in
this week
so I want I want to not this is what I
want to do I want to do it right here I
want to enter to win without purchasing
it says I can do that where how do I
okay
it says here it says making a purchase
right or a payment will not increase
your chance of winning a prize yeah yeah
so here's the thing it's literally
illegal okay
to require you to buy something or pay
to enter
a sweepstakes
so how do I I want the code no no don't
get the code how do I sue well that's
what I'm saying I want the code I can't
get a code I want you could normally go
to the hey can you adjust can you do me
a favor yeah yeah do me a favor
literally if you will will you will you
text Ben myzealous I'm serious see if
you see if he's see if he's available I
want to ask him about this live on air
if he's available he's probably not he's
a busy guy but he can give us a quick
answer say hey
um I I need a legal quick legal take on
this trump card because we may have
found something here
um this is uh because the official rules
on the website this is the website I'm
on it
it says no purchase necessary enter to
win
and what Gabe Sanchez is saying here is
that that is the way that uh sweepstakes
works is
um have you have you seen the uh
monopoly McDonald's
uh documentary where yeah were they were
they uh the guy was stealing the million
dollar tabs the million dollar um no no
I haven't seen it but I heard about it
but I haven't seen it it's it's really
[ __ ] crazy and like um I don't I
don't understand like when you watch
document you're like ah did McDonald's
not know but it wasn't them it was this
third-party company that ran their
sweepstakes right McDonald's just it was
just their store so what happened was is
a third party company that would run the
game essentially right
and maybe that's what's happening here I
don't know maybe that's what is
happening with this Suites I seriously
doubt it yeah um because I'm sure we
read more in this language uh here it is
yep here we go
there we go sponsor administrator
sponsor nft
there it is there's the in Park City
Utah uh oh here no administrator
National Sweepstake is he
um he's unavailable oh yeah he wouldn't
be up for another hour okay well
um you know that's how it goes attack
goes sometimes
um I just thought I'd get a stick but
understand I mean he'll probably confirm
he's probably gonna do well he's
probably gonna do a video on this yeah I
would imagine oh I I 100 agree on this
because here's the here's the actual
sweepstakes company National sweet
sweepstakes company so there is a
sweepstakes company that is actually
running the game The Sweep State
sweepstakes part of it national yeah but
this is all under the rules again that
you don't have to right you don't have
to purchase right well um here's here's
the um how to enter
um there are two ways to enter okay so
there's two ways you can purchase in an
ft all right beginning December 8th
which is weird that you were be able to
purchase these December Asia area that
that makes that's that's a little sus
and doesn't that make you feel
suspicious about this game this
sweepstakes
um
so you have to go to the website hold on
when when Trump prizes which no one
would [ __ ] know unless they looked at
this okay when when Trump prizes.com go
there and see what that looks like
before I head over there
okay oh no but you still need the
[ __ ] code okay so yeah this is
[ __ ] illegal okay so so let's see if
we can find where you get the code no
purchase melon alternative method of it
here it is so you gotta mail in that's
probably what's going on here oh this is
the beginning [ __ ] look at this
beginning November 28th
so this has been a sweepstakes for a
long time he's just now um buying into
this or some [ __ ]
um continuing out the sweepstakes entry
period that blah blah
um envelopes mailing an envelope to the
um the New York address
Newark New York uh let's see
information blah blah blah where does it
say you this here you go sweepstakes
code will be returned
in a self-addressed postage paid
uh Vermont resonance envelope provided
to each with the fact okay so so here's
what here's here's how you get the code
you have to mail in and you got to do
all this [ __ ]
um it has to be a number 10 envelope you
know there's all kinds of [ __ ] Hoops
you got to jump through number 10
envelope it's just a regular letter
envelope
um but they're probably the reason why
they're saying that is so that they can
throw out ones that aren't right yeah
the ones that don't meet these standards
they can throw them out uh because look
here postage address uh email email and
uh email address in non-black pen
like literally literally non-black it's
like black or blue is like pretty much
legal standard well I know but I'm just
saying I'm telling you I know they're
they're making you jump through all
these hoops and then if you do it again
what was that on this this is this is it
I'm doing we should we should mail in to
get this code seriously all right so
basically use red ink
well I mean what whatever we got to do
um yeah and we should um we should see
if
um Ben and the mizella's brothers want
to want to work on this to see if we can
get this code to do this thing okay so
you have to basically you have a month
in three days or so
to send in this thing that's postmarked
no later than also what the [ __ ] 11 59
okay whatever fine 11 59 p.m Eastern
Standard Time on January 18 2023 so
you've got a month and a few days to get
this in and postmarked all requests for
sweepstakes codes must be received no
later than seven days
following the end of the sweepstakes
entry period okay so it it can't they
won't accept it if it's after January
25th right
well and here's the thing here's this is
how it's not illegal this is how they're
getting around it is because this is how
you can actually receive one of these
goes without being hidden
that's because here's the thing you'd
have to go in read through this and say
oh uh
oh my God this is because no no no
person realistically no no one but us
would ever do this [ __ ] and we're doing
it live here and really maybe we should
cut this and [ __ ] send it to see if
Midas wants to put this on their YouTube
channel because no one else is going to
do this [ __ ] and we're doing it live no
one else is going to go find the way to
mock this [ __ ] now the way that we are
uh okay so here's what was the other it
says something will be a little bit okay
so uh mail for this mail in alternate
alternate sorry mail for this mail-in
alternate method or
our eventually sent to any other address
scroll up a little bit
will be disqualified and destroyed wait
what is the [ __ ] does that
means you got to read this with a
fine-tooth comb and you got to make sure
you're following every single step
because if you miss one of these you're
out [ __ ] sponsor May reject any entry
yep in its slash there they'll look
pronoun all right
whoa whoa wait a second they're wokers
oh my God they're using pronouns well
not pronouns but they're using you know
they're using uh possessive right you
know like yeah
well they them I mean isn't that the
same it's there yeah I mean yeah and
it's the same it there's a description
if the entry is part contains any legal
or offensive activity basically if
a bunch of [ __ ] that was like a bunch of
swear words [ __ ] porn so what we
should do is we should do a couple
different injuries and see what happens
I'm dead serious we should we should we
should do one entry that's our control
that is absolutely tries to go by the
letter of whatever this [ __ ] says and
then do one that does not a couple that
do not and see what happens
that's what we should do because it's
not going to cost us that much I mean
other than the time to figure out
exactly what we got to do with each one
of these son of a [ __ ] okay so I
don't I I don't know the case but Andrew
Lewis says
um pretty sure this is still illegal
using the Pepsi versus Harrier jet yeah
well uh the Pepsi Harrier jet thing
because I watched that documentary as
well that was a they had a civil lawsuit
and and the guy the guy who actually
challenged Pepsi lost
um in that in that sweepstakes because
what they were saying because it's a
different thing because this is this is
imaginable right like you can imagine
someone paying 99 for a digital image
right and then being part of a
sweepstakes when you buy that image or
if you do this [ __ ] circus thing
where you gotta jump through hoops to
get your code for the sweepstakes now
the Harrier jet thing is that they were
giving it away for Pepsi Points that you
collected when you purchased the Pepsi
um thing and but what what the judge
ultimately decided to watch documentary
um is that no one would take that
seriously no one would think that Pepsi
was giving away a Harrier jet they would
give away Pepsi you know like leather
jackets and hat yeah yeah you know that
sort of [ __ ] okay so number five here I
think um is important too oh it says
maximum number of sweepstakes entries so
we can do a hundred entries per person
or household during the sweepstakes
injury
now this is kind of funny though and the
reason why is because
you can do 100 entries but if you go up
here they're only going to give you one
uh where was it
um
I think that was the right section there
was somewhere it said you can only
receive
um one code in this one oh right yeah
yeah so when you're when you're sending
the entry in
um as the mail-in alternative
um you're only going to receive one code
you can't get more I think that's what I
said of course this is all [ __ ] fine
print [ __ ] so you'd have to you'd have
to send in a hundred
letters
no well you can send in 100 letters
we're only going to give you one code oh
well no well this says limit of 100
entries per person
meaning you have you can purchase a
hundred images
and you'll be able to get codes for
those images I think is what they're
saying okay okay so here's the prizes
there are 2 533 nft prices that is so
why that's such an auditory number
I don't know
um all Redemption items available in
sweepstakes fifty four thousand okay so
that's the total value well you know
what's funny about that is can you
imagine asking Donald Trump personally
like face to face how much is it worth
for me to have dinner with you he would
say way more than 55 grand yeah well
there's got to be some there's got to be
some legal reason why it's it's like
that
56.95 like I'm sure if I look this up
right now like 56
and now remember remember this is being
run by a sweepstakes business not not
Trump himself right I'm actually giving
them the benefit of the doubt that they
know how to lock this up to make sure
that it's all legal beagle stuff right
I'm assuming that's probably why there
must be like it feel like that's such an
arbitrary number that it has to be
something
I don't know here's well here it is here
it is so sweepstakes um Redemption item
description so you can win one ticket
oh boy to a 2000 what to a two thousand
person president Trump Gala dinner oh so
this [ __ ] is going to come out
and do his I've been cheated yep yeah
I've been cheated uh the election was
stolen speech
he's literally giving these [ __ ]
things priceless
[Laughter]
he goes
right there you can't put a price on it
says it right there one one one ticket
to a 30-minute meeting meet and greet
with President Trump as part of a 200
person group at a location this is
really this is where it gets hairy all
location yeah undisclosed location at a
time a time and place of which we will
determine clothing optional
um and grabbing grabbing genital
optional
um the thing is what's weird about this
is the quantity is 15 here and it's
supposed to be a 200 person group how
the [ __ ] does that work I don't know I'm
assuming up here it's 150 of these and
it's a 2 000 person group I'm I'm sure
he's throwing an event and then he's
like all right we'll just throw in 150
but then I but this what this shows me
right here is that to attend a trump
event it just cost you 75 right like you
go to a Gala it's 75 average well
yeah Gabe these are Priceless right if
you're going to beat him in person
here's this um individual 20-minute
meeting
with President Trump at Mar-A-Lago I
wonder if you get to see the top secret
documents in his desk drawer at the date
and time determined by sponsor in its
sole discretion there's only one of
these available
could I could we win this one
would that be some [ __ ] crazy we
entered a win and we win the [ __ ]
ticket for a 20-minute meeting oh my God
a golf game costs 300 oh so yeah so
there's a one hour golf game yeah one
hour that you won't even get through I
don't know how many like like how many
holes you can get through of golf I
don't well I mean with him it would be a
lot because he's like in the cart he's
like yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
right yeah and he doesn't use the path
he just goes
um yeah it pisses him off actually like
the groundskeepers and [ __ ] it pisses
him off apparently but there's only one
of those that's a 300 value so it only
costs 300 bucks for three people well
actually Four president Trump
uh the winner and two guests to to golf
at Trump Golf in Palm Beach it only
costs 300 bucks for an hour wow that's
crazy I would almost doesn't include
that does not include the fees you have
to get together I would almost bet that
if if if if someone asks Trump like how
much does it cost for four people to
golf for an hour at Trump Golf yeah
thousands of dollars it's one of the
best golf courses ever so valuable and
here he's valuing at 300. you know the
reason why he got Crim his organization
got kremely charged with like 17 counts
of fraud this is why [ __ ]
artificially inflated the value of this
is what they offer you're looking at it
right here okay okay so this this is a
good one here oh God individual 10
minute Zoom call
with President Trump at the date and
time determined by the uh no no read the
next one read the next this one here
yeah okay so this is one ticket to a 2
000 person here we are at 2 000 people
yeah he's got the crowd size of mine 20
minutes what the [ __ ] 2 000 people on a
zoom call
I I hold on I gotta look this up Zoom
call capacity
no way zoom's not even possible Zoom
call capacity uh yeah a pro account all
right here we'll go Enterprise is 500
participants and add-ons are 500
participants or a thousand so the max
can't even ever have one time is 1500
participants so maybe they're running or
maybe they're running two Zoom calls
simultaneously I don't know but you know
what's funny about this is this is a 2
000 person Zoom call right right two
thousand right now up here up here in
the 2000 meeting years only 150 winners
oh my God what a [ __ ] joke this is
let's see if there's any uh there's a
dining gift card at Trump Tower Ooh Yeah
Boy Oh exciting you'd have to go so you
have to go or spend money oh just
[ __ ] great well you have to spend
money at the [ __ ] drunk Tower yeah
well you have to you have to go to hotel
you have to go to the hotel in Las Vegas
you have to go to the hotel in New York
you have to go to their other hotel to
use them
oh my God okay hold on so one one book
of our journey how much does it actually
cost I think it's more than that our
journey together costs on
uh on Amazon
it's 75 bucks
it costs you 63.69 the list price was
74.99 but wow
but so it's 75 yeah just the retail no
one would [ __ ] pay that question
which by the way which is [ __ ]
[ __ ] because you know what that book
is made up of it's all photos from the
White House for yeah it's our photos
well no no no no this is the big problem
those photos were because typically
White House photographers will say great
over the time that I was with them
here's a book of my collection right
they get to publish it and they get to
publish it and before she was able to do
that Trump was like not mine and then he
[ __ ] published the book and took all
the photos that's how [ __ ] I mean
it's typical and on brand for him but
he's scum he's scum he's [ __ ] scum
well here look here 18 hole golf game
Force foursome they're gonna have a
foursome uh at uh
I can't I can't this is [ __ ] I can't
take anymore of this [ __ ] 500 this is
crazy okay so um before we go because
we're running out of time like literally
we're running out of time quite possibly
someone's gonna make his way on to
bonehead for sure oh I I could imagine
this is
Surefire bonehead winner today because
everyone don't forget don't forget to
subscribe here at at YouTube you can
vote on the community tab on the Johnny
Michaels podcast Channel
um tonight
I'm sure that um some nft new and the
new NF tier is going to make it on the
bonehead list so don't forget to vote
there you can also go to digital
bonehead of the week at Tony Michaels
pod you can vote on Twitter oh my God
this is so ridiculous um but I do want
to play Let's see if I can find it here
find it back the John Boehner
um and it's I just I uh Gabe I want the
little in here John boner
um where's the because there's like a
five minute video but I don't hear it
this is the short one this is him losing
his [ __ ] because I think this is
hilarious oh wait that's that you got it
yeah I got it but it's and I am on the
wrong window here we go
[Music]
on the Trump website
paste uh boom okay so we're running
okay run that time run that time okay
here's the John Boehner clip here's him
um balling over Nancy Pelosi everyone
take a look at this this is fantastic
this is what I was actually going to do
two hours on today but Trump delivered
us a grift I mean a gift let's yeah
I'm Madam speaker I have to say my girls
told me
tell this
how much we admire her
Dave Sanchez
he has the worst fake real cry ever what
he he is whenever I see when I've never
seen the Grinch and John Boehner in the
room at the same time if you ever look
at the facial expressions that he just
made on that as well as the facial
expressions let's say Jim Carrey mace in
the Grinch
overlap those two they look pretty close
oh my God I just love that John bainer
is a former Republican speaker
the former Speaker of the House
Republican Speaker of the House in this
day and age has to openly uh cry because
he loves Nancy making me cry right now
there is so touching there's no touching
everybody do not forget again to
subscribe here at the Tony Michaels pod
you can vote on the community tab or
bone of the week tomorrow is bone end of
the week go vote on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod on Twitter we you vote you
decide who is the nft loser of the week
this week we will break it down tomorrow
and maybe we'll have more of a legal
analysis from Mr mizell's maybe he'll
give us what is legal what is illegal
until then same time same place
Surf's Up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's mewborn headass Beacon